this capsule we will see a new
parent learning algorithm
necessarily passive the sentry box
adaptive dynamic programming then
previously we saw an algorithm
learning by necessarily passive who
is the direct estimate
it's an approach that makes it similar
at from service learning this is to
to say that we will learn from
fathers who are an entry his vow he
is acquired visit s is then from his
the target for each pass that goes
to be the weighted sum of rewards to
from s
so when we estimate among others kelly
the value for state 1 2 but we had
a first father who said that if I
starts at the state 1 2 youn and c where i have
possibly arrive in value of 0.76
there is another test that was the same
but it's actually where we rather
observed that from state 1,2 and
possibly the sum of the rewards
and that I observed up to a state
terminal was 0.84 and finally
I had another one where I still had
once 0.76 who was my second
test threat only if my learning
father music corresponded to for a
entry that state 1,2 to see in my
historical death what are the states
who when did I visit the state
1 2 what is the sum of the rewards
associated to a terminal then to
just average everyone and
all these values ​​there so what's that
it's a bit like a shape
learning super user but so dense
that if the targets were obtained at
from tests so simulation by
against direct destination will ignore the
recursive relationship between values
for different states for example the
recursive relationship between the value at 1 1
and the front bar 1 2 actually we have
as definition value that baroness
state is related to the value in
others and you have premium
and weighted according to actually the policy of
do a tradition of svs premium if I
here is the action then hesse
according to my policy so for example in
our essay 1 we saw earlier
his did not say ended up on state 3
If, on the other hand,
thing was information by
report to state 3 3 that was visited
but in fact we could have inferred that 3
2 real good anyway
pretty fast since 3 2 and adjacent to 3 3
and 6 years too much we observed a
transition of possibly 3.3 a
tradition in fact from 3.2 to 3 3 on
should be able to use that for
use the information so the tests
where I visited 3 3 to influence my
estimate of the value in 3 2 so if
what the second approach we're going
see for learning but
passive reinforcement offered this
approach it and call programming
adaptive dynamics and go it's from
take advantage of the recursive equations
between the different values ​​of v2 is
so the approached by programming
adaptive dynamics that I note their
pda
so that's the acronym I'm going to use
so the close relative pda does not learn
directly stop function actually
what we're going to do is we're going
learn a transition model to
from the model stalking transition on
will use our equations that
define our recursive equations
antivaleurs to infer what is the
value of monclin involved by this
transition model
actually if I have an estimate of
world and Belgian attraction can
solve these equations here so that's
among others, a problem that is solved
when we do
the algorithm of the iteration by
political in each of the three
deliberations and ordered on a
given policy is my model of
transition I have to calculate the value of
this plan then we have a way if we
gives tensile model to estimate the
associated value and the idea is actually
that in apprenticeship by pda in fact this
what we will do is
constantly refined our model but at
any time
our transition model is going to us
to obtain an estimate of
parents and to estimate our model of
traction what are we going to do is
use the frequencies of the transitions
which are observed in the tests this to
to say that our estimate of the
probability that if I went you have
and that I do the action given by my
political that I make a transition
to a new author's premium but I
I'm going to estimate it as just the
sum of frequencies including the number of
time that I passed from the state is this l
state of prime for each of my tests
I'm going to sum up for all
tests and finally I'm going normalized
to have an instruction who are at
1 in just the frequencies
for each of the tests the number of times
that I reached my state is this so the
name is not that I visited the torres
in in all my and it's finally
doing we are mostly testing
I give here the solo code that is available
in the book rasouli norvig I'm not going
go into all the details I want
give an example that is going to be maybe
a little more illustrative the for good
understand the algorithm but the idea
it's that our agent every time he
there is a percept called here that
basically corresponds to the state in
which I come to transition s premium
is also what is my signal from
reinforcement that I got
we also ask ourselves here that the agent a
internal memory of what was the state
before or where I was and what
is the action I would have done in this
state there so my algorithms and it's this
who will do is that if I were to have
a state so and it's not us it's up to
to say that I'm not at the very beginning of a
try i'm going
clement the number of times I've been
enough such rates and that I have done
the action ok the previous action
then I'm going to increment the number as well
of times that for action to when I
found myself at leicester sg transition
to the state expresses if what I come
observed a charcoal to observe that when
I was in the state is what I did
the action at I arrived at the state
mind I'm going to increment the number of
once I observed this event there
and from these conclusions but I
can now summarize my model of
transition with my new accounts
updated 2 the number of times I
went from shouting to you
left from htc knows it value
for which justin mapp reality of
transition / standardization constant
that the number of times that I have
found the state is what I did
reaction to this be from this model
I'm going to use the grid
of policy evaluation with my
currently estimated transition model
so this actually corresponds to
solve the system of equations
recursive for my function dallas and
and finally if I'm a state
bep terminal I will reset the
previous volumes the previous action to
null pointers then otherwise but I
will remind me that now to do
since my state is my state of mind
even then my action to it is the action that
was specified by my policy so
the action actually that my agent is going
take it's going to be the action dictated by
my policy worse that puts specific
because I'm learning
easy so someone you specify the
political what are we going to do as an example
to clarify all that imagine
the following environment at g3 and as0 s1
s2 I have a reinforcement function of - 0
point to 0 - 0 point 1 es1 es2 factors
destiny of 0.5 which is determined way
arbitration could have chosen I could have
choose one in this case and g1 and in
this case what is different
we notice that it's quite similar
for a previous example when we have
talked about terrasson by fleeing bullet to
his political father
in this case too it will actually last
to be a terminal state
if i reach s2 i do more than
transition to other states the test
will determine
and then the initial state is 1 0 and the
politics i'm on tahiti to
louhans s 0 selection to 1 and s complete
action at 3 so here the action smells
of alphonse that's not going to interest me
my father's perspective of learning
same thing for action
I find the action on2 here in fact I
will never take it in s1 11.0 I
always take action is so I
always a part of 0.12 to stay at
0 and a 0.82 chance part and will be the
time noticed that we do the game you
gives what's the environment but
in the perspective of my agent actually
I know there I do not know these
qualities there all that does observe
that observe a certain tradition
this transition there in fact she was
champion and according to his probabilities
so initially we will assume that they
have no connection between floors and
observed no transition so this is a
as if from the point of view of the agent
all states were states
terminals and that means that in fact
the value in s 0 it's going to be the
reward at 0 which is less 0.1
same thing for s1 ps2 it's going to be the
reward of 2 which is from the following of
its magic not that their agent between
in the simulation and then from scratch
following the policy returns to s 0 and
then it means that for the moment
since I observed what from
0h price reaches 0 and so from that
in fact what it implies
what it implies is that according to my
agent the transition model is that
if I'm politics from scratch
the policy of att 1-0 and 2-1
the Latin part and other states and 2 0
so that gives me this new system
of equations here it is I am disappointed
imagine that he is observing a new
transition this time 2 0 has a
lure now my model of
transition from scratch and set to
day
I once observed that I stayed
to 0 once I passed is this
so that means that according to my model
transition estimated
I have a quality of 0.5 to stay at 0 and
20.5 to stay ace
so my system of equations for the
values
the summer basically updated my
transition model was updated
only for the transition from
zero so that's just this equation
succeeded that you update I'm doing a
other action
according to my policy from
now I observe that part of
the addition I make a voltage as0 so
now for my equation for
the marine pageantry
I have a relationship between these rights are
there and the value to zero and my model of
transition for the moment cross that to
from the rushes can only do
a transition from eze to go to
and I can not make a transition to
others and from scratch
now my try but my wife that
I went from 16 0 I went back to
s1 which makes that now I have observed
that twice in three I went from
zero to st
once on 3ds 0 I stayed at 0
so now as he is from
tradition tell me that the value zero that
their head moment necessarily bigger
second time factor holds the
bar eur10 two thirds the value s is
finally I arrive n 1 and finished at
from the rushes a grip as two
so that's what's observed in this
simulation there and so I was leaving from
transition that tells me that from rs
I have one enjoy a half finish
ace lasts half an hour
go back to 0 and that's reflected if in
my system of equations so after we
does this test the poster one could
estimate values ​​for this policy
there that I followed as0 ses-2 simply
by solving this system of equations and
that's how programming is
unique adaptive works to estimate
are worth them now in fact
that at any time I had a system
of equations that I could have tried to
solve hockey is so in fact even in
middle of one and dry to estimate
given values ​​and so I have not
need to finish a test to get
an estimation
updated new estimate of my
values ​​contrary to estimates
direct who she to update my
values ​​if I do a new try it
must I complete leave in full
so that's a property of the
adaptive dynamic conversion which
could happen though is that
for if I do not have a constant anymore
small as 1 simon system my estimate
of the transition distribution is not
very well estimated it could be that my
system be not reversed and that's
so one of the reasons we
may still be able to have
a second factor that is more
small that the association I wish
just to mention here but it's
not something that was playing
many insisted so one of the ways of
solve this problem there in fact it's
basically to always have their
little thomas small 1
but know that we do if we have a
transition system that is such
that there is always a probability to
from any state of
to surrender to a state
terminally in this case we would not have
need to have a second factor
which is strictly smaller than
but if at any given time we actually
benefits and we do not have precisely
enjoy not we to go from
any state to an end state
according to the system estimated at a time
given that it may be that a problem that
conceive not able to reverse this
system of equations and so it's just
a slight difficulty when we can
meet that I wish in Zionism
so we've already seen when we saw it
iteration grid by policy if I
transition model
I can solve the system of equations
recursive between values ​​in different
states so I can do it a thousand and
in this form the sib is equal to aix
then simply inverted system nor
payment is reinstated xb to get
my values ​​that will match
excessive variable against this
sinister
it's an expensive operation
she is up to both statesmen so
the cardinal tds at 3 and so that's
something that is very expensive if
we really have a lot of toasts that
is often known in the
relatively complex problems so if
we had to reverse systems of equations
after each observation
it could be problematic a
approximation that can be done
similar to what we do down there
liutauras china actually used
an iterative method to estimate but
so that's what I can do
son is initialized my vector of
values ​​life here at any values
for example I could the the estimated
the initial 0 and there I can interest
between updating from the right to the
left
my vector of life values ​​with the term
of law in my system of equations
then to do this until I have
reached until values ​​only
not change besides the changes are
smaller than a certain outcry so
in fact what we observe here is the
same algorithm as in the group
of iterations by values ​​there it's
different is that here I do not have a max
on the shares because I have a
policy that I must follow so I
not to change the action I take in
different actions here I have a
policy then that I have to follow so
so that's why we could use
this iterative method putting it site
now if I roll them if I
runs from a value of 0 to
are not necessarily more effective
than to pour the system of equations by
against if I have a good initial value
it may be that I was converging in
more rations and actually imaginons
I already have before
try again
a first estimate of vedes I
could use it as a
initialization to get my ma
new estimate of the value for
my dish so finally the tution too
it's just observing a single transition
to clean that interest premium know
very little impact on my new
estimating my transition model
so very little impact on what should
to be the new value for my dish and
so an interactive approach more
the initialization of the mont tables of
value v from the estimated value
previously could converge very
quickly so this is possibly a
approach can be more effective
but in practice there are others
explorations that exist that I
mention very quickly here we
could just terminals and the
number of iterations so tell me to
Whenever I steaming my
values ​​my values ​​for my plan to
from my transition model
esteemed I simply want to donate without
leave rations and I will not do more
so that at the beginning my values ​​are
not very well estimate but if I
repeat several times after each
observation then reducing but
previously estimated value as
initialization after each observation
it could possibly converge
to good estimates also exists
sweeping procedures I refused to
english plater sweeping where are we going
keep track of how much
but my value to different states to
tendency to load one will prioritize
to update some states that have
big values ​​of two modifications
so of grace for the communes on
big changes in value for
his states so I invite you to
consult the nails learn more
on it but this type of modification
so has it an iterative method that a
use the last estimated value
is the kind of br i refused who
described here it's the kind of things
what to do if we are able to
solve problems or the space of
states is much bigger
so that's good stuff to know for
apply in practice an algorithm of
adaptive dynamic programming
unlike direct destination the
close relative pda can learn
after each observation as I have
mentioned previously do not need
to wait for the end of an essay to
get an estimate of the values ​​and
I would add that sometimes doing it is
possible that the reward function
not specified a priori so we get
pose is we knew what is the
rewards reward function for all
the possible states we used in
the definition of our system
of equations but it may be that it is
also something that is observed by
by our agenda the environment so
in this case also in fact what we're going
to do is we will also estimate
this reinforcement function there it's
to say that at the second initial flight i 0 and
would be a very simple estimate
as soon as we reach nonito
will we replace the zero with the
reinforcement that is observed
we want to use that we will now
finally know for this state there
that sound reinforcement
it is the reinforcement that we will use
in our system of equations in
the agglo deserves that we saw previously
all that implies is that at
very early
if the state in which I find myself
currently expresses and new well I
actually going to take my chart that
contain the value of reinforcements
and thrown a chair at 0 and now I
will assign it to the air reinforcement
bonus so that is part of my father
his silos that is part of my
observation at the current moment